if you've been following this story in
loudoun county virginia the judge has
sentenced that 15 year old gender fluid
fluid student involved in those two
sexual assaults at two different high
schools in loudoun county to a
residential program not jail time for
those assaults he'll be placed on the
sex offender registry until his 18th
birthday now the racial component of crt
has mostly been debunked thanks to
parents
standing up across the country for their
kids at school board meetings and we
also have to remember that a key crt
concept is what's called
intersectionality and the proponents of
crt say it's quote the way in which
different forms of identity are affected
by race class and of course gender or
whatever else they want to come up with
to divide us so don't forget gender
neutral bathrooms are also part of this
crt push let's talk about this now with
dave rubin host of the reuben report
here with me in studio and dave i got
your book here i don't actually we can
hold it up right here i don't have to do
the graphic this time
everything's better it's tactile listen
before we do anything i'm not sure how
we're doing in terms of diversity here
because i feel like we have equal
amounts of hairspray and very similar
jackets yes we are terms of
intersectionality and connecting our
oppressions not sure we're basic white
males but as we talked about yesterday
is white men who are often times victims
of hate speech facebook pointed that out
but let's talk about this
um scott smith the father of one of the
victims who he was arrested at school
board meeting we all saw that video you
know he said that this whole thing
caused a huge division in our community
and they were the ones accused of lying
about this sexual assault for political
gain i cannot imagine the frustration of
these parents not just here but
elsewhere yeah well look this story is
such a perfect example of almost
everything that's wrong with our entire
society at the moment if you believe
that your perceived depression whether
it's your gender your gender identity
your sexuality your skin color all of
those things if you believe that your
perceived depression is the most
important thing and then once that's put
into the system the system is pretty
much going to collapse around you
because all sorts of people will be
afraid to say oh no that trans person
happened to assault a kid or this black
person did this or this girl did this
you have to put this in an
intersectional calculator where
depending on what your oppression is
this is what we call the oppression
olympics you have to decide oh no this
person person should get a little escape
by because of that oppression or this
person shouldn't escape by because of
this and of course the white
heterosexual christian male that's at
the bottom of this hierarchy um so all
all of these cases where you see these
things happen it's like none of this
should surprise us this is the end game
of crt this is the end game of wokeness
and intersectionality you know you don't
you can kind of see this scenario coming
up in this situation it's dangerous i
mean this kid put on a skirt said he
felt like a girl one day went into the
bathroom and you know and did it twice
the judge said you know from what i read
in those reports scared me and they
should scare families and scare society
regarding the boy's psychological
evaluation during the sentencing
you know and i think what also is
problematic here is the way the school
board tried to cover this up initially
well they cover it up because they've
bought into wokism so somehow if you're
trans you can't be the offender somehow
you are the offended but that's why this
is all such nonsense if you just remove
remove gender identity or the trans
issue from this if a young 15 year old
boy assaulted a 15 year old girl in a
bathroom regardless of what gender the
bathroom was we would all know something
was wrong by the way you could reverse
the sex it happens less in that case but
if a 15 year old girl assaulted a 13
year old boy we would all know it's
wrong but because they've added the
trans piece into this everyone sort of
steps back because nobody at the school
board nobody in the administration at
the school they don't want to be the one
to say
oh no maybe this is a problem that we
have this trans kid in the wrong
biological bathroom right because
they'll be called a transphobe and that
is the worst thing that you could
possibly be called
22. yes worse than being racist i guess
even even today
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell